age ausgedacht und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video dürfen natürlich
euch jetzt gut wir haben extrem frühe 6
uhr mich geht es jetzt nach dortmund im
flohmarkt und ich dachte mir kommen ich
nehme euch mal mit es werden wirklich
interessant heute natürlich fühle mich
gerade wie so ein galileo moderator mich
dass gerade erzählt hat naja gut draußen
ist es noch dunkel ab ins auto und wir
sehen uns dann gleichen dortmund wieder
an erkläre ich euch mal was leute
vorhaben bin gespannt
was kalt drei grad los geht's heute was
geht ich melde mich nun wieder dann hier
mal kurz aus dem studio um das ganze ein
bisschen nach zu kommentieren euch ein
bisschen was zu erklären warum wir das
gemacht haben was dahintersteckt weil
das ganze ist halt nicht eigentlich nur
für meinen youtube-kanal ich dachte mir
nur heute kommen wir mal die kamera mit
ist jetzt bestimmt witzig und der extrem
witzig es war super langer tag heute
waren von 8 uhr bis 14 30 uhr flohmarkt
dann haben wir abgebaut ganze sachen
zurück dann waren wir danach mit
aufgenommen denn erst in zehn oder so zu
hause an und kommen genau aber erst mal
ging es damit los wir sind zum flohmarkt
gefahren hatten dicke paletten dabei und
haben die dort aufgebaut okay leute
mittlerweile angekommen in dortmund
rennen ist der flohmarkt wir auch schon
aufgebaut er ist es so wild natürlich
das ist ja auch das erste mal dass ich
hier bin puder erfahrung so hier geht
man drauf das ist unser stand da ist
schon ein kunststück macht angekommen
hier ist noch die zweite palette dass
ihr sondertransport es kommen direkt so
viele leute die bühnen darum wir wollen
alles mitnehmen das ist so krass das ist
meine erste flohmarkt erfahrung und wir
haben ja echt gute sachen wir sind hier
die richtigen brocken
im fernsehen alles vorher sonnenbrillen
ein bisschen
kurz zum hintergrund das sorry der felix
und ich wir nehmen aktuell an einem
fernsehformat teil das kann ich auch
schon sagen das heißt die retouren
profis das startet auf rtl kommt aber im
15 elften raus könnte gern mal
reinschauen ich rede da wir kein geld
aber es macht eigentlich spaß und
deswegen steht die wahrscheinlichkeit
auf werbung ja und deswegen waren wir
auch unter anderem halt auf dem
trödelmarkt um dort sachen zu verkaufen
in dem format geht es darum wie der name
schon sagt wer steigern retouren und
verkaufen sie weiter und ein paar halt
von uns oder wir haben uns das überlegt
wir haben bock wir gehen auf dem
flohmarkt das war mein erstes mal auf
dem flohmarkt ich war vorher noch nie
auf dem flohmarkt aushalten weil um
sachen zu kaufen aber so wirklich mit
eigenem stand noch nie und ich hatte
keine ahnung wie das würde ich wusste
nicht wie das in reinster flop macht das
ultra laune oder wie jetzt was sind das
für menschen und so oder mit was die
menschen kommst du in kontakt und ich
kann euch eines sagen ich habe diese
sechs schon heute morgen erst war
arschkalt aber ich habe extrem genossen
weil es so einfach witzig neben mir der
typ ich kann ihnen nicht klar die ganze
zeit billiger billiger billiger billiger
billiger letztere ist billiger billiger
billiger belegen geht es doch gar nicht
jung ich habe das immer noch im kopf ne
billiger billiger billiger billiger geht
immer angebot angebot angebot
zwei euro kann es mit dem superding
billiger billiger billiger billiger
billiger billiger geht es doch gar nicht
braucht etwas will man hat noch bevor
überhaupt die hier ist so schön streiten
wie üblich sondern dokumentiere unseren
stand aufgebaut
waren nur ein jugend ist für meinen
youtube-kanal hier vielleicht
grundsicherung fleißig tool und und
firma gesprochen wie viel umsatz wie
heute hinlegen so viel exil ist das
jetzt vielleicht zwischen fertig
gemacht und dann kam mir meine ganzen
kunden zu uns dann haben wir verhandelt
dies dass wir hatten wirklich so viele
sachen darum legen also das muss ich
noch sagen wir hatten zwei paletten dort
stehen mit über 1000 produkten drin
wirklich spielzeug irgendwie handy
equipment alles mögliche auch
fairerweise muss man sagen sehr viel
schrott die beiden paletten die wir mit
auf dem flohmarkt genommen haben da
haben wir ja ich sag mal fünf bis sechs
und euro roundabout für bezahlt was
denkmal ordnung ist unser ziel ist es
damit schon über 1000 euro zu verdienen
war gespannt ob das heute hinhaut ich
will jetzt nicht zuviel spoilern ihr
werde es gleich sehen was passiert ist
leute ihr könnt ihr jetzt mal schätzen
was glaubt ihr wie viele kommen am ende
bei russen sind das die schweiz spielte
war da müssen wir einen schöne acht euro
kriegen
also kann man wirklich nicht meckern
fünf euro
keine chance für fünf euro nicht mit und
ich werde ich sie hasse dich ich mache
nie wieder so was mit dir was sie sich
davon
uns liegen lassen april ihnen schon mal
im moment als polygamie
ich habe mich köstlich so leute seien es
zwischen partie wir müssten ungefähr
aktuell schon bei 140 euro liegen was
ganz gut ist aber wir sind auch schon
bestimmt einheits turnier deswegen da
muss noch einiges rumspringen damit wir
hier mit dem linken fuß gehen ich
bezweifle das aussehen oder felix dafür
hier unseren einsatz eines kurdischen
also auf dem flohmarkt zu gehen bedeutet
wirklich durchhaltevermögen man muss
manchmal auch auf die zähne beißen ich
will wirklich fertig und es läuft noch
nicht so gut wie ich es mir aber na ja
erst lief es nicht so gut aber dann kam
immer mehr leute immer mehr leute und
wir haben auch r handelt und hier und da
und das habe ich heute auch gelernt auf
dem flohmarkt rest kommt vielleicht
manchmal so ein bisschen respektlos
darüber wie man miteinander redet aber
die kunden die sind so direkt dann bin
ich auch immer direkt zurück gewesen so
man deswegen das wollte ich auf jeden
fall einmal gesagt haben das hat nichts
damit zu tun dass man irgendwie
respektlos ist aber man ist halt ehrlich
und muss knallhart verhandeln und dann
wohl darum gefallen es ging nur um zehn
cent es ist halt so auf dem trödel aber
wenn ich sage 150 der sagt 50 cent für
ein produkt was eigentlich 19 euro
kostet es war schon echt kastner
erfahrung für mich so jetzt aber ja
nochmal was fehlen die kunden felix
kannst du noch mal schreien einmal kürze
schreiben wir jetzt einmal auf und
dachte er was auch sein
33 weiß hier reinkommen wir brauchen
jetzt hier euro unterstützt hier
billiger billiger billiger geht immer
mit
sind doch zwei handschuhe dann auch zwei
euro kannst doch nicht sagen für zwei
handschuhe ein euro also nicht menschen
diese handschuhe heute eigentlich noch
billiger billiger billiger geht immer
müssen wir aber wie felix sie klammert
von verschiedenen insgesamt 300 euro an
die 300 euro würde ich sagen ein
bisschen haben wir noch da muss raus
bringen wir sind so an die sache
rangegangen dass wir erstmal die ganzen
guten sachen die wir haben auf dem tisch
ausgebreitet haben links und rechts und
alles was so klein schrott war wollten
wir für einen euro in den paletten
lassen was man darin herumwühlen konnte
das haben die leute auch wirklich
gemacht werden durchgehend kunden die in
diesen paletten rum gefühlt haben du
konntest die auch zum teil wirklich der
felix hat die so belagert die haben
immer mehr gekauft hatte das gefühl
manche haben da so wollen wir müssen was
kaufen bei vielen habe ich mich auch
gefragt wollt ihr dann verbissen nimmt
es mit der eine hat zum beispiel am ende
eben die sieben thermobecher gekauft
also ich brauche nur einen aber ja klar
man kann es ja verschenken aber es war
einfach geil es hat spaß gemacht und ich
war mit so vielen leuten in kontakt ich
hab auch von einigen habe ich so die
lebensgeschichte erfahren die haben
einfach drauflos geredet der eine hatten
erzählt ja meine enkelin wie ist das bei
euch gewesen die ist zwölf und die hat
einen freund der 16 das kann doch nicht
sein da dachte ich hier bin ich jetzt
sehe ich dachte dass trödelmarkts
neukunden die mindestens 30 euro
nicht wie
viel zu bezahlen waren
ich habe mir das stimmt er ist passiert
unser bester kunde ist es okay wenn du
bei mir auf 'youtube' kommst ja
alex abonnieren bitte
leute wir haben noch so viel herum
liegen wir wollten heute alles loswerden
jetzt richtet ordnung und wir sind weit
entfernt von gewinnen felix oder ich
habe leichtes jetzt kannst du nochmal
einmal scheint alles
zusammen wollen wir jetzt hier für 200
verkaufen aber irgendwie genau und so
schritt der tag dann immer weiter vor
die zeit ging eigentlich schnell rund
außer dass es arschkalt war ein
kamerateam was dabei war auch sehr kalt
hatten vier grad heute morgen und wir
haben jetzt am ende mal kassensturz
gemacht heute daraus ist jetzt extrem
regnen aber haben wir unser geld dann
können wir da noch was drauf rechnen man
muss sagen wir haben gestern
ich weiß nicht genau wie
dann würde auch so falls ja dann tomaten
und hier haben wir jetzt also das hier
sind jetzt 310 euro das heißt wir haben
noch jede menge und war leider die über
geblieben ist mir noch verkaufen also
ich habe da viel positiv wirke ich
damals waren wie viele leute das wetter
bestimmt trotzdem war es witzig ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe mir von dem
tag mehr erhofft ich habe gedacht es
wäre geil wenn wir hier 1000 euro
rausholen probleme hat es war nicht so
viele kunden da der flohmarkt war
irgendwo in dortmund in der nordstadt
kann euch gerne die adresse in die video
beschreibung packen und ja deswegen
mussten wir würde ich sagen die guten
sachen und alle weg gegangen aber die
hälfte von allen muskeln wieder
mitnehmen wir haben heute dort circa 300
bis 400 euro verdient los an anderen
tagen noch den einsatz haben wir noch
nicht wieder raus aber ich hoffe dass
das noch klappt morgen gehts weiter ich
hätte am liebsten natürlich einfach 1000
euro auf dem flohmarkt verdient und euch
das jetzt erzählen können aber so läuft
leider nicht oder so lief es heute nicht
es war trotzdem eine super witzig
erfahrung und ich bin mal gespannt was
wir aus dem rest noch rausholen klagt
heute wie gesagt weil 100 400 euro
irgendwas dazwischen las wir gern noch
nach oben da werden wir irgendwann
nochmal zum schlag gehen sollen billiger
billiger billiger merkt euch das geht es
doch gar nicht nehmen mit und david haut
rein zschau